I think really tough for us from a
professional standpoint because you know
we all hoped that we would be able to be
on tour and and seeing our viewers and
we were gonna hold fan events around the
finale of of the show and you know all
of that is you know everyone has to stay
safe it's it's just you know for us it's
sort of just disappointing because you
want to give the fans as much of
yourself as you possibly can in this
time and that's where the charity
initiative came in because we were all
sort of thinking what do you do with
this time and it's not very productive
to be promoting your show at this point
we're not like doing talk shows or
anything like that so how do we handle
this this time that we all have into
something really productive and so we
put together the ship's Greek gives back
initiative for feeding America and food
thanks Canada and within 24 hours we've
raised close to $60,000 so it's been
it's been unbelievable what happened who
died who died did Patrick die Patrick
didn't die David then why did you
startle me awake like this my mind went
straight to some kind of unthinkable
tragedy but I can't believe it to
actually hear that you know the family
journey because it's so bizarre because
you know I've basically been crying for
the better part of a year I'm an
emotional person like at the best of
times so this has really been I know
Annie's basically been making fun of me
for a good nine months just about yeah
the tears that have been flowing but
I've had to say goodbye to these
characters in the writers room then I
had to say goodbye to these characters
when we shot it then I had to say
goodbye to these characters when we
edited it and now I have to say goodbye
to them again you know now that the
episodes are being put out for everybody
to see I thought at this point I would
be less emotional than I am but there is
something really beautiful about these
episodes and and the
the message of hope and love and
acceptance being put out there in a time
when I think people hopefully need it
following the series finale though there
will be a one-hour special that will air
what can fans expect in that special a
writing David as a career character was
something that I just wanted to do I
didn't do it to make a political
statement it was just who he was in my
head yeah it's it's gonna be great it's
it's a look behind the scenes of our
sixth season and you get to see
everything from table reads to our last
day on set to everything in between
and I watched it recently and it's
pretty great it's pretty emotional next
you know the smelly day is gonna be a
very emotional time for me
[Music]